hey this is presh talwalkar
i'm thinking of a 10 digit number that
uses each of the digits 0 to 9 exactly
once
and the first n digits of the number are
divisible by n
what could my number be
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video
there are names for the properties of
this number
a polydivisible number has the first n
digits that are divisible by n
a pan digital number uses each of the
digits from 0 to 9.
this puzzle is asking for a poly
divisible number that is also pain
digital
you could write a computer program to
run through all the possible numbers
which will be over 3 million
possibilities
in this video we're going to solve the
problem using mathematical logic and
reduce this down to only 10
possibilities using the rules of
divisibility
to get started we need the 10 digit
number to be divisible by 10. this
forces the last digit to be zero
next we want the first five digits to be
divisible by five
this means the fifth digit has to be
zero or five
since we've already used the digit zero
this means the fifth digit has to be
five
just from these two digits we've already
reduced the number of possibilities to a
little over forty thousand
let's continue
we'll now consider that the first two
digits are divisible by two the first
four digits are divisible by four the
first six digits are divisible by six
and the first eight digits are divisible
by eight
in other words
the first n digits where n is even are
divisible by even numbers
so that means there must be even numbers
in the even spots
i'll denote this by a blue rectangle
furthermore we have exactly four even
numbers remaining to be placed in four
spots
that means these four spots will use up
all the remaining even numbers
therefore the remaining spots in the odd
numbers must be odd digits
now let's consider the first four
numbers we need this to be divisible by
four
the divisibility rule is that the last
two digits of the number have to be
divisible by four
we also know that the first digit has to
be odd but it is not the digit 5 which
is already used
so which two digit numbers satisfy this
property
we can start counting up from 0 and look
for two digit numbers that are multiples
of 4 with this property there are only 8
cases to consider
and there's a pattern in these cases
the last digit of the number is either a
2 or a 6
so that means
this tangent number must have the fourth
digit equal to two or six
we'll write out two different
possibilities
now we're going to figure out the six
digit
we know that the first three digits are
divisible by three so that means the sum
of the first three digits is a multiple
of three
the first six digits must be divisible
by six that means they must also be
divisible by three and therefore the
first six digits must also have a sum
that's a multiple of three
now since the first three digits have a
sum that's a multiple of three this can
only happen if also the fourth fifth and
sixth digits also have a sum that's a
multiple of three
so let's consider the fourth fifth and
sixth digit if we have two plus five
that gets us to seven
now we need to use one of the even
numbers that's remaining to get to a
multiple of three
we can't use four or six
but the number eight would work seven
plus eight is fifteen which is a
multiple of three
six plus five is equal to eleven
we need to use one of the remaining even
numbers to get to a multiple of three
we can similarly conclude this digit
would have to be four
now let's consider the first eight
digits of the number
this needs to be divisible by eight
which means the last three digits have
to be divisible by eight
so we wanna look at numbers in the eight
hundreds and the four hundreds we also
know that the middle digit has to be odd
but not equal to five
and we can't use one of the even numbers
we've already used
so we could start counting from 800 and
go up multiples of eight
see which numbers satisfy this property
we do the same thing for the 400s
there are only a few cases
that could possibly have
an odd number in the middle and it
doesn't use one of the even numbers
that's already remaining
in the case of the 800s we've we can't
have 832 or 872 because we've already
used the number two in two five eight
so we remove a couple possibilities
there similarly for the four hundreds we
have to remove the digit 6 because 654
already uses the digit 6.
so this leaves us with two numbers in
the 800s and two numbers in the 400s
so we put those in we have four total
possibilities for a number so we've
actually filled in a lot of digits of
this number
we didn't fill in one more digit
we have exactly one even number that's
remaining
this has to be the last even digit
in the first two cases that'll be four
and in the last two cases that'll be
eight
now we have exactly three digits
remaining in our number
these will be odd digits in the first
case it'll be 379 then 137 then 179 and
finally one three nine
so how can we reduce the number of
possibilities further well we need the
first three digits to be divisible by
three so the sum of the first three
digits has to be a multiple of three
if we look at our first case we have
something for something and we need to
have three seven or nine in these places
we can try to figure out sums which have
four in the middle that'll get us to a
multiple of three
none of these are going to work so this
entire case can be removed we will never
get something that will satisfy the
property we want
let's look at the next case
we have 1 3 and 7 and 4 in the middle
so 1 plus 4 plus 7 is equal to 12 which
is a multiple of 3. so we could have 147
or 741.
we'll do the same thing for the next
case we have the digits 1 7 and 9.
now there are a couple of sums that get
us to a multiple three so that leads to
four different possibilities for the
numbers
the final case is similar there are two
possibilities to get to multiple three
which leads to four different cases
so we have 4 plus 4 plus 2 which is a
total of 10 different numbers
so we've reduced this from over 3
million numbers to check and there are
only 10 possible numbers that this could
be
now which number is the answer well we
still need the first seven digits to be
divisible by seven so you could check
the first seven digits divided by seven
see which one's divisible and there's
only one number that works
this is three billion eight hundred and
sixteen million 547
290 and that's our answer
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and like this video
please check out my books there are
links in the video description